[Music]
people in the United States still want
to be part of the American Dream story
of success but what actually is the
American Dream and is it still
attainable traditionally the dream has
been associated with a successful career
wealth and homeownership popular
conceptions of the American Dream also
focused on the ability to achieve more
success than one's parents causing some
to believe that the opportunity to
realize the dream is declining yet the
results of the AEI survey on community
and society suggests something different
significantly more people believe that
the freedom to live their lives as they
choose and the ability to have
fulfilling family lives are more
essential to the dream than
homeownership wealth and having a better
quality of life than their parents we
found that about 8 in 10 Americans
believe that they are living the dream
or are on their way to achieving it and
only 16% of people say that becoming
wealthy is essential to the American
Dream this is good news for Americans
today our results show that people still
believe that family and community matter
and that the majority of Americans
believe that the American Dream is in
their reach is the American Dream still
alive for you let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AAA